[Musique]
et c'est bernadette groff qui est avec
nous concert départemental du canton de
brunstatt et maire de brunstatt combat
d'habitants à brunstatt minutes face à
marquette mais vous faites est peut-être
vous mêmes diplomates et 25 étaient tout
à l'heure donc vous attendre à mesure
que brunstatt extrêmement chaud
vous faites partie vous bernadet des
nouveaux élus du conseil départemental
avec votre binôme daniel adrian et vous
avez été félicitations les seuls à être
élu dès le premier tour en mars dernier
ça quand vous avez appris les résultats
les scores c'était quel état d'esprit il
est vrai que le soir même on s'y
attendait pas on n'était pas très sûr on
avait très peur bien sûr et surtout
quand moment donné quand les différents
résultats arrivent et des différents
villages ont séduit fluide à quelques
voix près peut-être que ça ne passera
pas au premier tour et ça a passé que
j'avoue que avec mon binôme ça a été un
énorme soulagement vous en alors on va
partir dans le canton de brunstatt un
territoire charnière finalement entre
mulhouse et saint louis et faire plutôt
bien son épingle du jeu par sa situation
géographique entre les trois frontières
reportage d'adrien labit
entre mulhouse et bâle se trouve le
canton de brunstatt un territoire rural
qui s'étend des rives du rhin aux
collines du sud go lieu de passage des
grands axes de communication vers la
suisse le canton tire parti de sa
situation charnière
ici la coopération internationale est
une réalité quotidienne pour les
citoyens comme pour les élus
c'est la partie française les trois
comme comme mes plates formes de
coopération transfrontalière regroupant
les cantons suisses nos voisins
allemands et les collectivités
territoriales françaises l'eurodistrict
trinational de bâle permet d'initier les
actions dans de nombreux domaines un des
principaux étant celui des équipements
qui ne peuvent ici se concevoir que dans
le cadre trinationale à travers cette
action et cette implication dans le tb
nous pouvons avoir des répercussions sur
l'ensemble des habitants de notre canton
à travers les équipements à travers le
travail aussi je sais bien qu ici dans
cette commune de l'inter nous avons du
monde qui passe tous les matins pour
aller travailler de l'autre côté et qui
sont touchés par exemple par les parcs
il du covoiturage ou par l'amélioration
de nos réseaux routiers ou différées
notamment dans
l'état
avec une part conséquente déjà 8 ans
travaillant sur mulhouse ou la suisse la
question du transport est fondamentale
le département soutient les alternatives
à la voiture individuelle à bartenheim
c'est une plateforme pluri modèle qui va
voir le jour son objectif favoriser la
liaison ferroviaire
à sierentz c'est le covoiturage qui est
mise à l'honneur avec la construction
d'un parking relais nos voisins suisses
moi il y a deux voitures qui viennent
chez eux le matin mieux tous se portent
alors nos voisins suisses cherchent
cherche à faire en sorte qu'ils aient
moins de voitures chez eux c'est évident
et de l'autre côté - l'autoroute est
engorgé le matin mieux chacun ce porte
le soir c'est pareil alors ce parking de
covoiturage a aussi cette particularité
ici à sierentz c'est que nous avons vu
un financement transfrontalier ce
financement bayonne partie de nos sous
qui viennent des suisses à travers tout
ce que nous travaillons transfrontalier
c'est le fender fonds qui nous permet
d'apporter 60000 euros sur les 150000
que coûte le projet le reste c'est le
conseil départemental dans le cadre des
ses tv donc des contrats de territoire
des actions qui concourent à développer
l'attractivité du canton dont la
population augmente vous voyez les
nombreuses constructions qui se fond
dans notre canton les nouveaux venus ben
ces nouvelles personnel sont intéressés
de savoir où je mets mon enfant d'abord
dans le primaire et ensuite dans le
collège où elle collège le plus proche
comment que ça se passe et c'est tout ça
ça incombe au conseil départemental
c'est à lui d'assurer la bonne gestion
et surtout faire en sorte que nos élèves
soient le mieux possible publics ou
privés peu importe puisque les collèges
privés sont aussi à aider par des
subventions de fonctionnement sur ce
territoire quatre collèges de public et
deux privés forme les futures
générations une offre d éducation riches
qui participe elle aussi à
l'attractivité de ce territoire
voilà on peut bien mesuré en fait
l'importance de l'eurodistrict sur ces
trois frontières allemandes sont
exactement alors vous ne partiez
d'autres quand on est plus au nord il
est justement pas forcément dans cette
route district trinational de bâle est
ce que pour vous c'est un problème mais
qui concerne surtout les mets trois
frontières bien sûr ce n'est pas un
problème parce qu'effectivement la
partie nord du canton entre autres mon
village est plus tourné vers ville
centre mais je dirais qu'à terme la
ville centre mulhouse a peut-être tout
intérêt également à travailler avec le
avec le canton de bâle et avec la ville
de bâle qui est quand même le plus grand
pib du monde ce qui là également c'est
que au niveau du canton je veux dire aux
facettes eurodistrict pardon c'est un
laboratoire d'idées c'est très important
ce laboratoire d'idées et ses
laboratoires d'idées a forcément des
répercussions et des retombées sur tout
le département non pas unique mais ce
que les répercussions justement on l'a
vu dans le reportage pas mal de
d'alsaciens en fait mon travail et
travers passent la frontière vont
travailler chez des voisins est-ce que
ça créé pour vous de la richesse a créé
de l'emploi dans notre canton oui mais
sur ça crée forcément à l'emploi parce
que ces frontaliers en pouvoir d'achat
quant à pouvoir d'achat construisent des
maisons conscience de jolies maisons
souvent donc forcément ça fait
travailler les et les petites des
petites et moyennes entreprises locales
ces frontaliers également font revivre
des villages je dirai pas ce que ces
villages qui se mourait peut-être un
petit peu nous achète des terrains ils
construisent des maisons et petits
commerces même s'installer à nouveau les
écoles fonctionnent à nouveau donc je
dirais un village avec des commerces des
écoles saint village qui vit à nous je
crois que ça paraît important le conseil
départemental vient de voter 600000
euros de crédits pour financer les
classes bilingues hors contrat de quoi
s'agit-il tout à fait donc ce sont des
classes bilingues qui ne sont pas
conventionné avec l'éducation nationale
vous savez qu'au niveau du département
même en alsace on tient beaucoup au
bilinguisme qui est important comment
disait tout à l'heure ne serait ce que
pour travailler en suisse ou en
allemagne donc ces classes bilingues
comme je disais non conventionnés pour
pouvoir aider ici classe a fonctionné
payer des professeurs le conseil
départemental mais une somme à la clé
sage et vous sauverez
arbitrage c'est comme l'école assomption
à colmar le collège de zillisheim où les
départements fournit donc une certaine
somme pour payer les enseignants
l'éducation nationale n'a pas
suffisamment ce sont souvent des
enseignants allemands qui ne
correspondent pas forcément aux critères
de l'éducation nationale française donc
forcément il n'entre pas
ce calcul a rien de grave je rappelle
que vous êtes concert départementale
canton de brunstatt on passe un petit
peu complètement au dessus il ya eu des
crues qui était extrêmement violent dans
le sud de la france et vous les crues
c'est un vrai problème mais l'électrique
constate ya des mines m on connaît bien
puisqu'on a eu plusieurs inondations sur
plusieurs années et à partir de 2 89 99
2003 2005 quand il y en a encore eu
récemment donc avec le conseil
départemental avec le service spécifique
qui s'en occupe on a décidé de créer des
casiers un premier casier a déjà été
fait qu'il fut à peu près une retenue de
100 à 1000 mètres cubes d'eau avec des
guides avec des gens spécialisés au
niveau du conseil jean louis tout à fait
d'aider des gens spécialisés qui peuvent
prévoir ces inondations absolue les
digues avec les pompiers locaux fermés
c'est à dire fermez le casier mais c'est
s'écouler l'eau tranquillement et le
deuxième casier de 200 à 1000 mètres
cubes à peu près va être réalisée
prochainement également placés sur les
progrès sociaux avec des oui comment
voyez tout voilà on est plus poil de
danse de protection des habitations
également pardon à venir anglais
allaient me reste 30 petites secondes ya
une maternité à brunstatt qui va voir le
jour où il a vu le jour non c'est une
maternité qui va déménager c'est plutôt
l'hôpital de mulhouse qui va déménager
sa maternité actuellement la maternité
et ouazine raoult d'accord et je
rappelle également un sens paraît
important que l'hôpital de mulhouse
l'hôpital emile muller est tout de même
le plus gros hôpital non universitaires
de france on est la maternité du asia
line va déménager dans monte donc du
docteur la niaque et de docteurs m'ont
gêné une grosse maternité de plus de
2000 accouchements par an qui va être
mis en place et c'est pour cela que il
ya des voiries mais on les voit bien
d'ailleurs les ils ont fait
départementale des routes d'accès en
fait il faut c'est qu'ils sont donc si
en plus comment dire un dossier qui va
être porté par le département par la
ville de mulhouse et par la ville de
brunstatt